salut je suis en pleine forme et je n'ai
même pas fatigué donc je peux continuer
à faire une vidéo par jour pendant un an
je plaisante c'est par rapport à la
vidéo d'hier que je dis ça et
aujourd'hui c'est le jour de l'astuce de
la semaine
astuce que vous m'avez demandé dans les
commentaires il ya une semaine à savoir
comment clore une discussion avec un
bavard j'ai trouvé que c'était une bonne
idée surtout quand on est quelqu'un de
gentil on aux patrons vexée la personne
en lui disant tu es toi je n'en peux
plus ça ne m'intéresse pas est ce qu'il
ya des astuces pour ça et bien oui
monsieur oui madame
il ya des astuces première astuce il
faut vous engouffrer dans une brèche
dites vous qu'il n'y aura pas de fin à
la conversation vous le savez ici que
vous savez où il se rend pas compte et
ça aussi ça arrive donc profité d'une
petite brèche d'un mouvement où ils
respirent parce que même un bavard
respire un moment donné pour prendre la
main expliqué que vous n'avez pas le
temps mais attention expliqué le
poliment en racontant par exemple de
manière succincte ce que vous avez à
faire ou ce que vous allez faire ou ce
que vous étiez déjà en train de faire
car ça ne les arrête pas que vous soyez
en train de faire quelque chose quand
ils ont envie de vous parler mais comme
on l'a vu dans de précédentes vidéos le
corps dit beaucoup plus que les mots
donc envoyé des signaux corporels le
premier signal à envoyer c'est que nous
regarder plus l'interlocuteur dans les
yeux regarder autre chose fait autre
chose en même temps bouger également
physiquement ne soyez pas statique à
côté de la personne soit de marché soit
de ranger quelque chose à côté de vous
faites autre chose en même temps même
quelque chose de futile peu importe en
clair soyez actif dans autre chose que
la conversation et non pas passifs à
écouter à recevoir l le bavard qui
n'arrête jamais si malgré ça ça ne
fonctionne toujours pas alors il est
temps de passer à une étape supérieure
c'est-à-dire exprimé clairement que
c'est la fin de la conversation mais
comme la première astuce faites le
poliment sur une des micros failli y
couper le et dit poliment
c'était vraiment un plaisir de te parler
maintenant j'y vais parce que j'ai ça ça
et ça affaire ne lui laissait pas le
choix encore une fois un bavard ne se
rend pas compte qu'il est bavard ne se
rend pas compte non plus que c'est
peut-être pas le bon moment où n'a pas
envie de se rendre compte peu importe
en tout cas il faut que vous repreniez
la main en mettant un terme à la
conversation votre ligne de conduite à
chaque fois vous amorcez quelque chose
soit d'exprimer que vous n'avez pas le
temps soit de clore la conversation soit
de la détourner une dernière fois c'est
d'être affirmatif est déclaratif si vous
n'êtes pas affirmatif ou déclaratif ou
si vous n'êtes aucun des deux dans ces
cas là ça va être une faiblesse et vous
allez lui rendre le pouvoir est
forcément si on lui rend le pouvoir le
bazar bay le garde avec vos proches
c'est un tout petit peu plus subtil les
proches et la famille
les amis très proches c'est pas
forcément d'ailleurs qui sont toujours
bavard c'est parfois c'est pas le bon
moment où vous êtes pas encore disposé à
écouter vous avait autre chose à faire
il faut être alors un tout petit peu
plus subtil faut respecter deux choses
la première c'est d'écouter la personne
un minimum savoir de quel sujet elle
veut vous parler et d'écouter un petit
peu sur ce sujet là vous pouvez pas
clore la discussion si elle n'a pas pu
réellement commencé ça devient malpolis
la personne a l'impression de se faire
bâcher c'est normal ça vous ferait
exactement le même effet avoué la
deuxième astuces la deuxième subtilité
c'est de fixer un temps défini dès le
départ mais de le fixer vraiment
verbalement écoute moi bien tu as deux
minutes pour me parler je vous demande
pas de faire ça de prendre un
chronomètre ou un minuteur juste de
notifier la personne à l'aide d'une
phrase un petit peu maligne comme par
exemple oui je t'écoute par contre
seulement 5 minutes tu allais 16h25 à
16h30 je dois partir absolument donc
vas-y dix mois en cinq minutes définir
le temps dès le départ permettra de ne
pas paraître impoli au moment de clore
la discussion donc les deux clés avec
votre famille avec vos amis proches
c'est d'être polie de penser vraiment
politesse donc écouter un minimum
définir le temps expliquer pourquoi et
d'être sincère n'inventez pas une fausse
excuse si c'est parce que vous êtes
simplement fatigué notifié la
temporalité en expliquant que c'est
parce que vous êtes fatigués vous allez
vous coucher vous allez regarder un film
mais n'a inventé pas une excuse de vos
proches le savent c'est désagréable
qu'on est alors placé aussi désagréable
donc il faut penser à ça j'espère que
ces quelques conseils vous serviront si
vous aussi vous connaissez un bavard et
que vous avez une anecdote la suite vous
pouvez me le dire dans les commentaires
je les évite tous et j'y réponds en
général plutôt en fin de semaine mais je
réponds à tout le monde
n'oubliez pas avant de partir de laisser
ce silencieux mais très efficace pouce
en l'air et surtout surtout abonnez vous
à la jeune avant de partir puisque le
mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an donc rendez vous demain à
17h ciao